feminism I want to talk about feminism
in it related to something that we
talked about earlier this week we talked
about and ignited a pretty pretty lively
discussion it is Western society our
Western values formed by Christianity by
modern Christendom so I want to be clear
here this is not proselytizing or trying
to convert anyone if you're an atheist I
hope that you get just as much out of
this as Christians because I'm going to
say some stuff that probably both of you
disagree with if you're a Scientologist
you should just skim right over this is
not for you no truth at all get clear
I've tested my feet and levels they
barely register so Western values and I
do see ACS alot say well you know what
actual values do not I don't need a god
that dictate values to me I don't need I
don't need some imaginary sky figure to
tell me not to steal or not to kill
humans inherently know that okay and I
think a lot of people who do believe in
God theists argue the wrong point
because I think those extreme examples
you would probably find most societies
have agreed even if they're not
Christmas sized that those are bad
things not all mind you you've had some
tribes who don't believe in personal
property but the other tribes did hence
the warring tribes some arrows are
coming your way so not every society
believed that theft is wrong but let's
not argue the extreme examples and this
is how it relates back to feminism and
the idea of a Western society I think
it's more interesting to talk about the
non instinctual values in Western
society for example Mercy Mercy was not
a global that mercy is not a human trait
naturally and it wasn't even considered
a virtue for a long time certainly not
an ubiquitous virtue to most people
until modern Christendom the idea of
forgiveness the idea of loving your
enemies the idea of fidelity now these
are some values that people out there
atheists and Christian or pagan whatever
it is may not necessarily agree with but
I am trying to say these are the values
that form the basis of the foundation of
Western society so I do believe that
Western society particularly the
American the United States society is
founded on this idea of Christians also
free well the ability to practice
religion or to be an HS or practice any
religion you want that doesn't happen in
a lot of other societies that stem from
other religions
so how does that relate with Semin ISM
well again with Western society there
were a lot of Christians for a while
they've been sort of run through the
dirt for believing in something called
complementarianism I'm sure you've heard
of this that leaves that men and women
have complementary roles to each other
and that this is foundational to a
society by the way that's about it
that's the basis of Western society it's
actually the basis of constitutionalism
the idea of limited government can only
function which is which is why they
encourage the proliferation the United
States of the nuclear family before
federal government before state
government for municipal government they
wanted mommy daddy and kids because they
believed that that was the best
foundation the bedrock for a society not
saying that it's necessarily right or
wrong I'm saying historically in Western
society that's why that has existed and
feminism absolutely flies in the face of
it and I think a lot of secularists and
scientists now when they wait to the
political correctness or finding common
ground with Christians saying you know
what men and women are different
this idea of complementarianism is
probably a better way to go about life
and feminists are saying it's easy for
us to see whether christians are not the
ugliness and the screeching and the
cackling of feminists that you see in a
youtube montage but at its root it
really is not compatible with Western
society and I would argue not compatible
with Christian values in Western society
let me explain to you why Jesus for
example was one of the first radical
feminists by the way classical feminists
if you look at teachings from the Bible
it talks about husbands being gentle and
kind to your wives loving providing it
tells wives to be submissive to your
husband's
now the word submit means to respect the
authority of husbands now if you look at
this what does this really mean this
prescription I always thought this was
interesting the prescription is
basically saying this is how your wife
receives love this is how your husband
receives love now we know this how many
people out there read the five love
languages right there's there's touch
there's quality time there's acts of
service those gifts there's I think
words of affirmation this is pretty much
something you'll read in any couples
book how does a woman receive love
generally in a relationship anyone who's
been a relationship I love you sweetie
kindness gentlemen all the time there's
achill touch how does the man receive
love in a relationship generally
speaking after words of affirmation at
words of affirmation acts as as our
judge respects will physical
in a different way but I guess that
submission meeting respecting the
authority in other words a man receives
love not by sweetie I love you honey
honey but when he slaps his kill on the
table having a woman who will help him
to put his feet up and recharge for the
next day because his wife loves him
enough to take care of him that is what
is occurring in the Bible at saying this
is clearly how men receive love which we
now know to be true this is how women
receive love
therefore you should give love this way
it's the best way to treat your spouse
and feminists absolutely despise it
because they want you to believe that
men and women are interchangeable and
men can do anything women can do women
can do anything men can do and it's a
general rule there's no difference they
can do it with equal or greater
efficiency and it's just not true to
give you an example again this idea of
complementarianism let's say a father
leaves Timmy and Kimmy okay the father
leaves Tim in community says listen
Timmy in my stead here I need you to
make sure you help Kimmy make sure Kimmy
gets whatever she needs be kind be
gentle with Kimmy make sure she said
make sure she's put to bed at the right
time Timmy I need you to make sure Kimmy
is taken care of and then if he says hey
Kimmy you heard what I said now listen
to Timmy while I'm gone these are the
father's prescriptions then when he
leaves Kimmy goes completely off her
rocker and just starts doing whatever
she wants not listening to Timmy at all
not respecting not submitting to the
authority of Timmy we just have to
disrespecting Timmy she's respecting the
father but that's in token if Timmy just
starts beating the ever-loving crap out
of Timmy
once the father is gone what's happening
there timmy is not just disrespecting
Kimmy though it's unpleasant it looks
painful does it does he's disrespecting
the father and these have been tenets of
the Christian faith as far as human
interaction between men and women and uh
feminists often revolted against that
idea right that's what they were volted
against with the idea of the housewife
of the mom they wanted to remove really
the female role from femininity and I
think you're seeing a lot of Sekulow now
finding ground where Christians have
always been saying you know what we're
not the same biologically and that's
okay and these are the truths that we
held to be self-evident for a long time
so I think it's a good thing and it is
an era where we can actually find common
ground
as atheists and I wouldn't even say
Christians atheists and sensible deists
so I think that's a good thing your
thoughts yeah men and women are created
equal in value but not equal in ability
in role right and you see that play out
throughout society but you're supposed
to serve one another you're supposed to
be subject to one another I love that
part in Ephesians the next verse was
like men be ready to die for your wives
just FYI
yeah I'm it to you be ready to lay down
your life for them just like Christ laid
down his life for the church by the way
that's never prescribed for women oh
yeah if you're not going to go die for
the husband again 90 percent of
something 90 or something percent of all
deaths in the workplace are male yes so
that you complain about pennies on the
dollar which is not true but we
undeniably die more and by the way God
was cool with it yeah yeah yeah women
just dated feminists they hate the S
word the submit word and what it's one
things I think people have just screwed
up so much because they haven't ality
the submission means like the like
submitting to Authority it's like ah I
don't want to but you know I better
bullet you know BAE the police otherwise
people never going to give them ticket
they don't they don't view it through
the biblical definition of lovingly
affirming your husband's leadership
right and lovingly seeking to carry that
out with whatever talent I think John
Piper talks about that a lot of
affirming your writings leadership in a
way that is honoring to him it's not a
it's not a oppressive no it's not like
Islamism it never ever die doesn't mean
always greet them or any but it is it is
a loving affirmation of this leadership
yeah exactly and again that's the way
that men receive love that these are
often issues and marriages usually money
and sex that usually comes down to the
way love is communicated and men receive
love in those ways and that's why men
inherently also what they work so much
to gain your respect women you know
they're out there most often if men are
working overtime it's because they want
to be a good provider they want to come
home and they want their wives to be
proud of them they're doing it for
themselves too but it's a big component
to it I will tell you as a husband the
first person I think about when I wake
up and the last person I think about
when I go to my to sleep is my wife my
wife my family and act as a business one
of my employees because it is my duty to
ensure that they are provided for first
of all my wife and and so when you're
doing that you're going out and you're
taking the hits
that's where respect and submission to
Authority comes in and the same thing
why
who you know basically she's locked
herself down to you she's tied herself
down to you guess what women if you look
at them in their own circles they're
very affectionate that's the way women
are they need to receive that kindness
that gentleness from their husbands so I
just thought it was interesting I think
it's an interesting sort of roundabout
way where we've now found common ground
so there you go here on louder with
crowler we get theological philosophical
and we find common ground as well as
telling Bill O'Reilly dick jokes hey
video is take another clip from the full
show Daily Show at ladder with credit
comm slash mug club or it's available
exclusively $69 a year that's less than
six dollars a month less than two
expensive cups of coffee or you can feed
an African child but just buy coffee or
join the Mudd Club
daily show a lot of excited calm slash
mug Club see you there don't feed
children